Добро — це безкорисливо ділитися тим,
чим ти можеш поділитися.
Добро — це розуміти,
тримати руку на пульсі і не зупинятися.
Як би важко тобі не було.
У нас є певний перелік магазинів,
які складають такий умовний маршрут.
Кожного дня відповідальна особа
з того чи іншого  магазину
відписує про готовність передати нам їжу.
У випадку того, коли магазин готовий
передати нам їжу, він віддписує в чатику.
Відповідно, наш координатор бачить,
що в такій-то локації
такий магазин може передати їжу.
Наприклад, до 13:00
ми збираємо повний перелік всіх  магазинів,
які згодні нам передати їжу.
Після того формується маршрут.
І вже волонтер, який виходить на маршрут,
знає в конкретно в які локації йому треба заїхати,
щоб забрати продукти.
В Україні є дуже багато різноманітних проблем.
Значна частина частина нашого населення
проживає за межею бідності.
З іншого боку, українці входять
в десятку країн, які викидують,
або продукують найбільше сміття в світі.
Значну частину того сміття складає органічна продукція.
І значну частину тієї органічної продукції
складають продукти харчування,
які ще можна врятувати.
Власне, «Тарілка» є таким універсальним інструментом,
який одночасно мінімізує такі дві проблеми.
Тобто, ми, рятуючи продукти
від потрапляння на смітник
в межах терміну придатності.
Передаємо їх малозабезпеченим особам.
Доброго дня, ми від «Тарілки» по продукти.
— Ви до нас? Ми вас чекали.
— Так.
— Чекали?
Ми є унікальним таким проєктом,
тому що виконуємо одночасно
і еко, і соціальну функцію.
Власне, в такому-от ідеальному симбіозі
«Тарілка» продовжує функціонувати станом на зараз.
Практика продовольчих банків є загальносвітовою.
У різних країнах Європи і в Америці такий інструмент,
як продовольчий банк,
є дуже дієвий і активно впроваджується.
Ідея створення продовольчого банку
в Україні належить Ростиславу Косюрі.
Це львів'янин. Він народився тут у нас,  у Львові.
До шести років він проживав тут в нас [в Україні].
Пізніше, разом з батьками,
він був змушений переїхати в Німеччину.
Там проживав близько двадцяти років.
Власне Німеччина є тією країною,
в якій культура продовольчих банків дуже розвинена.
Після певного часу він вирішив
повернутися назад до Львова.
Побачив, що є проблема,
яку можуть вирішити продовольчі банки.
І, чому б не спробувати?
Так ми стараємося зробити культуру
продовольчого банку загальнонаціональною.
Тому що уявіть собі,
якщо би декілька  «Тарілок» було у Львові,
якщо би в кожному обласному центрі
була своя власна «Тарілка»,
чи декілька «Тарілок»,
скільки їжі ми би могли врятувати.
І скільки людей, які перебувають
в потребі ми би змогли нагодувати.
Тому дуже важливим є бачення
і розуміння «Тарілки» як такого
дуже хорошого інструменту,
який може зробити дуже-дуже багато добра.
Аню, можна я попрошу тебе,
щоб ти забрала продукцію?
А я просто тут буду з машиною.
Раптом би хтось виїжджав.
М'ясне — туди. Ковбаски.
А там є якісь овочі, фрукти?
— Немає нічого такого. Добре.
— Все м'ясне.
Червона рибка.
Добре.
Я почула це від своєї знайомої з «Пласту».
Це мав бути мій пластовий
додатковий проєкт
для того, щоб перейти на інший ступінь в «Пласту».
Але так сталося, що ступінь став мені неважливим.
А організація вийшла на перше місце.
І я вже давним-давно забула,
що я хотіла робити тут.
А зараз займаюся всім, чим тільки можна.
У моїй сім'ї вийшло якесь
інше ставлення до продуктів.
Я тепер завжди всіх контролюю,
щоб вони чогось часом зайвого не купили.
І всі мої родичі і друзі також
часто запитують про проєкт.
Тож в цьому залучена не тільки я,
але і все моє оточення.
У нас була дуже важка початкова
комунікація з нашими сусідами.
За браком інформації, за браком розуміння
діяльності  продовольчого банку,
вони практично всі виступили
проти відкриття «Тарілки» саме тут.
Нам довелося провести таку зустріч.
Зустріч-знайомство з ними.
Ми запросили всіх активістів.
Розказали їм про проєкт.
Були запрошені представники міської влади,
які пояснили,
що «Тарілка» на цілком законних засадах
користується тим приміщенням.
Також ми залучили представників духовенства,
які могли з більш релігійної точки зору пояснити,
що «Тарілка» — це про добро.
І як мінімум будь-яка релігія вчить добром ділитися.
І нічого поганого немає, що якісь молоді люди
тут організовують таке маленьке добро.
За результатами зустрічі
ми отримали дуже позитивний фідбек [відгук].
Тобто, люди, які прийшли нас насварити:
чим ви тут займаєтеся, що ви хочете тут зробити?
В результаті [вони] стали нашими прихильниками.
Є молоді сім'ї. Конкретно з того приміщення,
які до нас приходять
допомагають з ремонтом,
систематично передають якісь кошти.
Нам вдалося переламати отакий стереотип
про «Тарілку» тут на місці.
І я сподіваюся, що зовсім скоро [жителі]
всього мікрорайончика,
де ми знаходимося,
будуть теж нашими або волонтерами.
Ну, і швидше за все, нашими відвідувачами.
Ми сьогодні об'їхали 7 магазинів.
Зібрали дуже багато класних паштетів. Я бачу.
Є сосиски дуже класні.
Є багато молочної продукції.
Є фактично цілий кошик овочів.
Маємо навіть тут імбир.
Якщо бачите, є баклажани.
Огірки. Помідори.
Частинка є хліба.
Різних паніні.
Ну, і є різні соленості. Картопля.
Тобто, досить непоганий такий продуктовий кошик.
Якщо можна так сказати.
— Привіт.
— Привіт. Як справи?
— Все чудово.
— Файно.
Добрий день.
— Сергій.
— Аня.
Відкривай багажник.
Будемо тебе запаковувати.
Давайте.
Кожного дня ми маємо іншого партнера-благодійника,
який займається харчуванням малозабезпечених осіб,
кому ми передаємо нашу їжу.
Обирається якась така точка зустрічі,
де наш волонтер передає їжу
представнику тієї чи іншої організації.
У вівторок друзі твої приїжджають.
Чудово. Вони дзвонили мені з Києва.
Ти будеш теж на зустрічі чи ні?
Та, думаю, що так.
Якщо треба, можу бути присутнім.
Бо «горять» вони.
А думаю, що зроблять класно, бо то в Києві.
Добре.
Потрібно буде їх ввести.
Підтримувати цілу весну і координувати дії.
Ну, ми залучили 7-8 міст.
Такі, які зараз є на зв'язку і що хочуть розвивати.
Ну, окей  [гаразд].
— Добре. Щасливо.
— На зв'язку тоді.
Є люди, які навіть кажуть: ми от живемо в Києві,
але ми хочемо приїхати до вас,
щоб зсередини подивитися як воно виглядає.
Я думаю, найближчим також матимемо таку зустріч.
І, я думаю, що після того як людина
вийде з нами на маршрут,
побачить, загориться тою ідеєю.
Точно можна буде говорити про те,
що найближчим часом
в Києві буде теж своя «Тарілка».
Зараз ми їдемо до багатодітної сім'ї такої,
яка живе в досить таких складних умовах.
І веземо їм продукти.
Оскільки вони зверталися і просили про допомогу.
Завдяки такому проєкту як «Тарілка»
і супермаркетам,
ми маємо змогу допомогти таким сім'ям.
І це є класно. Це добре. Це надія.
Навіть в мене, коли до мене дзвонять люди.
Хтось дзвонить — треба цукор,
хтось — по щось інше.
Я допомагаю людям,
які вже 15 років не виходять з хати.
— Дай Боже здоров'я!
— І Вам також!
— Я не сам. Я з друзями. Привіт.
— Заходьте.
Що уроки прямо тут робите? Так?
[дзвонить телефон]
Я ще зайнятий. Передзвоню.
Ви просто будете приїжджати
і в один день забирати пакети.
Угу.
— Домовились?
— Домовились.
І все.
— Що це за фрукт?
— Це авокадо, напевно.
Це буряк!
Авокадо...
[сміються]
Я буду йти вже з друзями.
Я радий був вас бачити.
Будем допомагати частіше.
— Отам лампочка така.
— Яка?
— Де вона?
— Отака.
— Яка така?
— Отам. Зверху.
— Ну, і що?
— І там...
Умф...  [сміється]
— І там світло є.
— Є світло.
Люблю тебе дуже!
Добре. Ми тоді вже йти потрохи.
Не будемо вам [заважати].
Сергію, велике дякую Вам,
що ви зайшли, що ви мені допомогли.
На здоров'я. Це завдяки зусиллям
багатьох людей
ми можемо якось робити щось на краще.
Як то добре.
Все до побачення.
— До побачення. Щасливо Вам!
— Щасливо!
Функціонування «Тарілки» воно також є і показником,
можливо, не зовсім зрілості,
але хоча би формування
такого громадянського суспільства.
І показником того, що вже почало в нас
все якось рухатися в правильному напрямку.
Важливо зрозуміти, що  не всі ми
потрапляємо з народження в рівні умови.
Дуже часто люди потрапляють
в ту чи іншу життєву ситуацію.
Через різні обставини.
Не всім щось в житті вдається.
Але потрібно завжди залишатися людиною.
Це зовсім неважко,
якщо в тебе є можливість комусь допомогти,
поділитися своїм часом, маленькими ресурсами.
І зробити добро.
Людина, якій ти допоможеш, візьме з тебе приклад.
І почне допомагати іншим.
Таким чином, ми створимо таку «піраміду добра»,
яка зможе допомогти великій кількості людей.